all right well we're popular for all our
wind that's what we have to brag about
this spring and boy we got more of it
today just spreading around the olive
ragweed grasses air quality moderate
unfortunately there's going to be more
dust in the air today and we're going to
be cooler than normal again yesterday we
were only 73 degrees this morning we're
down in the 50's and feeling even cooler
with those southwest winds which have
been gusting over 25 miles an hour
overnight some of those gusts were over
40 miles an hour they've calmed down
just a little bit red rocks 47 degrees
this morning prompts in the 40s it's
chilly out there we're looking for a
high
today again just like yesterday 74.
sunrise was 5 39 and sunset at 7 36. we
should be in the mid 80s mornings should
be in the mid 60s we're going to be down
in the 40s tomorrow morning it is going
to be chilly so we've got a couple of
areas of low pressure to the east and
especially this deeper one to the north
of us that's what's going to keep
cranking the wind and one right on top
of us along a stationary front had a lot
of cloud cover over the last few hours
but the clouds are already starting to
thin out another day of red flag
warnings fire weather warnings for
southern nevada all the way through
arizona and new mexico new mexico still
battling that huge wildfire that's
bigger than the city of new york it's
unbelievable east of albuquerque all
right 74 degrees today southwest winds
easily up to 30 miles an hour and still
windy tonight again with mostly clear
skies low 50s officially tomorrow
morning but there will be a lot of
neighborhoods in the 40s so better get
the jackets back out in the sweaters the
high tomorrow is only looking 70 degrees
then we're going to jump up up to 30
degrees warmer by the weekend to our
first triple digits of the year sunday
monday tuesday those triple digits hang
on oh my gosh what an extreme